people make videos like this all the
time sharing the same old secrets well
in this video I'll be showing you seven
legitimate hacks you've never seen
online before allowing me to get 300,000
views on my first ever video 600,000
Subs in one year over a billion views
and allowing me to do this YouTube stuff
fulltime Point number one pockets in
virality so I'll use entrepreneurial
videos for example when most guys are
starting off their channels they'll
analyze someone like Iman Gody copy his
titles and thumbnails and basically make
watered down version of what he's
already making I've always known that I
wanted to make videos like this where
I'm talking to the camera giving you
guys business advice but rather than
starting making these videos right when
I started off my Channel with zero
subscribers I did this trick pocket and
virality so what exactly is it I knew
that I wanted to go viral as quickly as
possible so what I did was I analyzed
what's an extremely trending topic right
now and your Tate and what has somebody
not done H mom reacts nobody did a mom
react to Andre Tate video idea sparked
in my head and within a week I had the
video filmed and on YouTube think about
it would you be watching this video
right now if you didn't already know who
I was probably not because there's a lot
of other guys who try making videos just
like this so you find something that's
viral a pocket inside of it and you
place yourself there some other examples
of me doing this were last June where I
made the pride Island and Muslim
training interviews how are
you I'm doing good it was pride month
everyone was talking about gay people
and whatnot so I went and I investigated
a pride event and then made a video
while I was traveling Europe in the
process remember anyone could have done
these same videos that I made anyone
could have done it you would have found
this thing that's viral pride month and
found a pocket inside of it that you
could have placed yourself to get as
many views as possible then after you
have a lot of attention if you want to
switch niches to something like this or
interviews whatever it is at least now
you gained a bunch of attention people
have seen your face and what you're
doing is you're retaining a percentage
of those people rather than just trying
to start going after it right away it's
a big reason why I did the mom reacts
videos for so long they're also fun to
make I love my mom and whatnot they were
doing well entertaining but I also knew
that it would be gaining me as much
attention as possible to then make a
pivot and retain as many of you guys as
possible so before I ever started this
brand I actually had one called Real
Talk stock so one of my first ever
videos that I made was if you invested
in x stock what it's worth one year
later now every single time I made one
of these videos they popped off so then
a few months later when I got into more
crypto content I just copied that same
Trend with the crypto Niche and a couple
months later when it was nfts I copied
that Trend with the nft niche anyone
else could have looked at me doing this
trend over and over and on their own
channel but nobody has their brains on
so I was the only one copying over and
over getting millions of views in the
process to recap this is analyzing
Trends across different niches seeing if
a topic Trend whatever hasn't made it to
your Niche yet and you're capitalizing
off of it I'm not going to keep ranting
about this I could talk about all this
for like a week straight but point
two turn scrolling
positive you're going to scroll on
social media sometimes I know you I do
it we all do it so the goal is to make
your NPC scrolling as productive as
possible to do this you're going to
start start bookmarking the content you
see into folders for example I have a
bunch of folders inside of my bookmark
Tik Tok for things like good hooks that
I see good examples of people utilizing
the Tik Tok creativity program beta good
examples of people marketing IRL
businesses music whatever it is
basically with every couple Scrolls I'm
bookmarking something into a folder now
there's a ton of different benefits to
this if I want to network with someone
that is making music I can send them
this list of good examples of people
promoting their music on Tik Tok that
way if they want to start an account
they already have a bunch of really good
video ideas that they can uh base off of
and they don't have to do all the
scrolling themselves if I want a good
idea for a hook I have a folder for this
if I need some more public interview
ideas I have examples already bookmarked
if I want a new way to style a Twitter
thread I have a whole folder for these
I'm not going to dive into all the
different folders I have for this you
kind of get the idea but the main
benefits of turning your brain on while
scrolling and bookmarking stuff is for
networking so you can always be
providing people value more video ideas
and you always have stuff to reference
and go back to point three study stud
those above
you this is something that a lot of
people get twisted but we don't want to
reinvent the wheel we want to take
what's working give your Spin and do it
better right now I'm working on making a
lot more highly edit videos challenges
this kinds of stuff you can see it in my
last 7-Day dopamine detox video I've
been studying Ryan Tran and Eric a lot
lately as I watch their videos I take
notes down in a document of the things
that they do I haven't yet implemented
some recent findings have been every
time they switch scenes the music either
lowers volume or it cuts to different
music or they completely cut the music
I've noticed that Eric is always filming
a ton of b-roll that he can always have
in his videos so I'm taking this stuff
that they're doing well like the music
changes storytelling different camera
angles and I'm implementing it into my
own videos in a creative way not
Reinventing the wheel but taking what
they do and doing it better in my own
way I'm actually building a full
explanation on my findings of these guys
and how to implement it into your own
channel so part one will be in the
webinar I'm hosting you can check the
link in my description to see if there's
any more more available spots it is free
but we're capped at 500 people another
way that studying those above me has
come into handy is actually back when I
started my channel initially if you look
at my thumbnails at the time compared to
the thumbnails sneo was posting when he
was very trending they're very similar
if you looked at the only other mom
reacts Channel you would see that our
titles are the exact same and if you
look at vid iq's video description you
would see that I copied his layout
completely and just did it in my own way
so looking at what other people do well
doing it better and in our own way not
just completely copy it get that through
your head on to point four cutting the
fat that last point I was talking about
external analysis analyzing others now
for this we're going to be doing some
internal studying once a week or
bi-weekly you want to do a full
analytics breakdown of all your channels
in this breakdown you're going to look
at the retention graphs on your videos
as well as your best and worst
performing videos with this you're going
to do the trick that I call cutting the
fat where you look at what's doing well
take note and keep keep doing it in the
future and then look at what's not doing
well and cut or modify it going forward
for example on my initial mom reacts
video you'll see that we had a dramatic
cinematic intro where we took the best
moments and then condensed them down
into 20 seconds and then gone to the
reaction we decided to test different
hooks to see if something would
potentially do better so we tried just
getting right into the reaction video
with just a quick one second popup on
the screen I'll pop it up right here for
you guys to check it out then when we
did our analytics breakdown we noticed
that the getting right into the
reactions not doing the cinem one
actually had better retention this is
actually a double w because now it was
less editing and less money out of my
pocket to have to edit that intro and we
were getting better retention on our
videos another example when the Tate
reactions were doing well we ran with it
we reacted to everything we ran to the
Tucker interview reacted to Tristan Tate
and your Tate part two kept milking the
out of it and then started testing
different things like moving out of the
red pill and reacting to like woke Tik
toks and stuff like that but none of
that wouldn't have happened if I didn't
do that internal analys is saw what was
doing well to keep doing and saw what
was doing bad and cut it this trick is
absolutely key which leads us into five
consistency think about it close your
eyes and think about it for a second if
you promised yourself that you were
going to post 100 videos no matter what
always analyzing trick four that I just
taught you about where you're cutting
what's doing bad and you're running
what's doing well it is quite literally
inevitable that you find success on
social media the only reason people's
videos aren't doing well is because
their videos are that is the reason 99%
of the time with social media you need
consistency and speed my mom reacts
videos were hot so I started pumping
three a week right off the bat then I
optimized my system so a lot of the
timely stuff was outsourced then I was
able to get to daily uploads you need
consistency and speed my mom reacts
videos were popping right off of the bat
I didn't wait a month to get the next
one out right away I started getting
three mom React videos out a week then
what I did is analyzed my systems and
outsourced a lot of the work that I
didn't need to be doing such as the
posting process the revisions a lot of
this different stuff I was able to Dish
off to my editor with the SOP standard
operating procedure and that way I was
able to start making these videos daily
within a month of starting my channel
for this video interviewing people about
Tate's release from prison not only did
I do trick three analyzing this guy's
previously successful title I also
filmed this video the same day Tate was
released from jail and posted it the
next day shout out to you for moving
with speed you're actually following T
speed speed speed speed anyone could
have done this anyone could have
interviewed people on this posted next
day and got the 500 views that I brought
in overnight unfortunately the Matrix
wasn't happy with fat cheese opening
appearance and we got hit with the
biggest Shadow band of all time I
usually won't say shadow bands are real
but you can check this out absolutely
ridiculous point six
networking the beautiful thing about
building your brand is it allows you to
network so much easier now to do this
you want to get creative back at the
start of the mom reacts videos I wanted
to network with sneo so what did I do I
made a video reacting to sn's craziest
takes then rather they're just dming him
some DM like let's connect
that's what 99% of you guys send me why
would I respond to that or a DM like yo
just reacted to your video go check it
out I posted an Instagram story saying
hey reacting to atne new video go check
it out as if it was just for my audience
but my logic was sneo was more likely to
look through his story mentions rather
than the thousands of DMS that he's
getting every single day and it worked
he responded to my DM following me back
and I was able to build that
relationship up after joining his
program I started joining live calls
just giving my two sense and then I
became a professor doing weekly calls in
there and now I was in business with
sneo which was kind of my goal the
entire time calculated chest moves this
is what you guys can all do too just no
one's thinking or using their
brain another example of me doing this
is I would react to Tate consistently
and then I actually joined the War Room
I'm not inside anymore so I can say that
now I think and two months into my
YouTube stuff I now had the Tates
reacting to me on a live stream I was
running lives with sneo my plans were
coming into play by networking
creatively for you as you keep building
up your brand you also want to find
creative ways to network with people
just like this and as you build those
initial relationships you want to
provide value to them as much as
possible to maintain those relationships
point two actually comes in handy with
this like I said before you want to
network with a musician for example you
can go to that bookmarked folder of
people marketing music send it over to
him and now he sees you as a valuable
asset to keep in his life this isn't
just for networking with influencers to
make videos if you're an editor and you
want to find clients all my editors that
I have hired have sent over a free
sample result and some even join my
program just to get closer to access to
me since I get so many DMS of the same
every single day the last tip that
I'm going to give on networking as a
content creator is as you build don't
only network with people of the same
subs and Below you you can start filming
with people who have 10 times more subs
than you right away I could talk about
networking tips for hours but just use
those tricks as you build up your
personal brand and now on to tip seven
short form
content you need to master shorts
everyone that has made it in the last 2
years has made it because of short form
content and and your tape sneo myself
literally anybody is blowing up the way
they are because they're getting
millions and millions of views on Tik
Tok Instagram reals and YouTube short so
what you're going to do is you're going
to consistently post two to four videos
on your shorts Tik Tok and IG res every
single day every video you make it's
going up on all these platforms on
YouTube for every short you're going to
connect the long form version of that
video to the short just like I'm showing
off right here now as you're posting
consistently you're only one viral short
away from getting thousands of
subscribers and potentially driving
hundreds of thousands of views to that
long form video everything in life is a
funnel so the main purpose of your short
form content is to get as many eyes on
you as possible that way when people see
your video on their recommended they
already recognize you and they're more
likely to click on it just like the
reason you're likely here watching this
video right now or they go and they
click on the long form version of that
video with the call to action at the end
like I just described an extra beautiful
part about posting a lot of short form
content is there's actually a bag that
you can make off this so I'll show you
some of my shorts for example this one
2.3k off of one short this one 1.4k this
one $800 and that's just on YouTube
shorts which doesn't even pay as much
the Tik Tok creativity program is where
you actually make bank right now
like these are some guys on my Discord
$2,800 his first month 10 grand 10 grand
11 Grand $1,300 6 days in you are only
one short away from not only blowing up
your accounts to where you can get a ton
of subscribers and views on that long
form video but also making thousands of
dollars if you just focus on finding
pockets in virality turning scrolling
positive studying those above you
cutting the fat staying consistent
networking and mastering short form
content it is inevitable that you go
viral and make thousands thousands of
dollars in the process I'm interacting
with you guys all the time in my Discord
server and if you want access for part
one of that live training that I
mentioned earlier make sure to check out
the webinar Link at the top of the
description and yeah that's basically it
for me guys I definitely recommend you
guys check that out congrats on making
it this far and uh I'll see you later
peace